we did little jail it took us five
months but we did aa piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's - Manny gang oh my oh my god I
need to talk to this [ __ ] you so the
developer II of this game emailed me and
he was like yeah the gate the level
isn't that hard and you can you can do
it yeah right
go go go go go go okay this [ __ ] oh
god what is happen I'm fine yes
they're super secure though elephant oh
my god I love elephants
this is [ __ ]
me
you got your test bro
MLG alright so now we got to jump back
in there let's do a test Jim alright I
think we can do yes okay now we're just
gonna not die from the dolphin that's
clearly not a dolphin see there's a
reason why we shouldn't have killed it
go go go go go go go go
ah no no no into the nothing it may be
over but it won't stop gotta do
everything every [ __ ] thing again
help big deal no big deal at all this is
my I'm fine we're doing that [ __ ] again
face I don't want to close my eyes I
want to punch something in the ass don't
tell my chick Oh God
great I forgot to talk to the black gang
so they're [ __ ] elephant isn't there
oh man if it what a funny head method
there we go attempt number I don't know
how many times I've died in this game
i've probably died more times in this
game than any [ __ ] game combined yes
alright
sparta go to go killers
go die no no fun no my heart was blinded
by help at this table
ballet ear Amin alright alright okay
here's the here's the deal yes you're
here go die we're gonna be careful now
no more [ __ ] around all right I'm
gonna take my time elephant tusk goodbye
a [ __ ] this jump is a little tricky but
we did it let's take our time go in oh
my god I [ __ ] it's fine it's fine no
need for panic yes okay all right we're
good
yes yes yes oh my god what is that kill
it that [ __ ] is wrong with you okay
yes all right you're so low my man I
can't believe you kill it instead of a
man just go I never want to see you
again
[ __ ] you okay now the giant wall is gone
go
yes oh don't die I can't that's I can't
die now check would ya oh god not this
part this part I remember this part
I can't holy [ __ ] this part is way too
[ __ ] hard alright
Jesus [ __ ] [ __ ] in the ass
Oh God
oh god I am actually did it jesus
[ __ ] christ okay all right all right
all right is that all you got
okay Oh
this is amazing
[ __ ] okay how do I hear this
I'm gonna caddy
it goes like why are you spitting on me
while I'm sleeping man living Jeff la
fonda el Vettes Victor oh go go Crudup I
go go power [ __ ] Rangers in my ass in
my ass I love ass in my ass I am ass in
[ __ ] you guy
I can do it Russ I just need your
support
god damn it Thanks thanks for the
support
there's just too many things there's
just too many things that can kill you
Oh God okay okay alright okay calm down
everyone's calm okay it's just what is
don't don't
oh my god I never made it this far
it's falcon lover hello sir no scope 368
6x6 oh excuse me where it's just pop out
sometimes there's a camel up ahead we're
smoking can you take him away from him
and go I catch your bed see you laters
Oh God
why is the camel smoking I gotta catch
him the [ __ ] where you going mate Oh for
[ __ ] sake how am I supposed to catch a
Pokemon god dammit I gotta do this [ __ ]
again how someone explain to me how oh
my god come back your [ __ ] I'm faster
than you
big oh come on seriously almost no oh I
got that [ __ ] you if I did help the
camel Hey
yeah baby video games [ __ ]
I'll be back goddamn camels rematch
[ __ ] out
why why do I have to do all this why so
much [ __ ] I gotta do okay go go go go go
suck a [ __ ] [ __ ] in the ass I can't
believe I have to do all this every time
is this I can't [ __ ] you [ __ ]
night no no no no no no but bed bed oh
god oh god son not crying yet come on Oh
what the [ __ ] was that I [ __ ] feeling
back
what's portal doing misty looks to me
like squirtle just learns how to use
hydro pump if you think you've ever been
pissed off you haven't played this game
Oh for [ __ ] sake go go go go go this is
my chance
okay yes yes yes yes ah yes this is
beautiful
this is [ __ ] amazing go go go go go
go go keep running keep running baby
Oh God there was a stone oh god what
that I don't have sight no go go go
just follow me and I'll help you finish
this level what does that mean oh god I
was supposed to follow his pattern this
is pretty good
yes [ __ ] amazing
alright let's let's take our coal here
okay got it yes okay alright there we go
just a short walk to the finish like
there it's a twerking monkey there
they're pretty dry some say you should
go to the monkey and show that you're
appreciated the twerking yeah that makes
sense
oh there it is I'm coming too
the [ __ ] was that that was a trick
alright let me get some of that yeah oh
that feels good this better not be a
fake goal this better not be a fake goal
I can't believe it I don't believe it I
don't believe it okay press we do local
- it took us five months but we did it
no big deal
are we on luck Batman new level leave a
like if you want me to check it out and
I'll see you the next one stay awesome
bros peace be with you
come on come on I don't have time I
don't have [ __ ] time for you Oh Toby
[ __ ] me Johnny Oh